طرح نائب رئيس مجلس سياده السوداني مالك
عقار خريطه طريق لانهاء الازمه في البلاد
تقضي بوقف فوري للقتال واطلاق حوار يؤسس
لمرحله انتقاليه كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا
في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات كيف نفهم توقيت
وبنود المبادره التي طرحها جاري ووصفها
بمبادره الحكومه وما مدى تقاطع هذه
المبادره مع مبادرتي ايجاد ومسار جده لحل
الازمه السودانيه ما فرص نجاح المبادره في
التوصل لوقف لاطلاق النار يؤسس لمرحله
جديده
[موسيقى]
خطاب السيد عبد الفتاح البرهان وكذلك خطاب
نائب رئيس مجلس السياده مالك عقار يتفقان
بعضهم البعض لا سيما من خلال
الحديث بشكل مباشر بان الدعم السريع ارتكب
انتهاكات وجرائم وفظائف حق المدنين وان
كانت
اشارات السيد مالك عقار اقل حده من اشارات
السيد عبد الفتاح برهان التي وصف فيها
محمد حمدان بانه اليهود اكبر مؤامره
تستهدف امنه وحده وتماسك السودان عده
الخطاب الذي اعددنا ان يظهر به البرهان
كانت هذه الحده غير ما غير معهوده في
الخطاب الاخير فضلا عن ذلك لغه الجسد كانت
تعبر عن ذلك فضلا عن ذلك هنالك الجزيئات
مهمه مرتبطه بسير العمليات العسكريه والان
ومنذ فتره حده العمليات العسكريه في
الخرطوم لم تكن لكل هذه الامور تؤكد بان
هنالك رغبه جاده من قبل المؤسسه العسكري
حتى اللحظه لم يقم بدور جيد بقدر يتعلق
الامر بالتعري المواقف
والدبلوماسيه وما الى ذلك لا اعتقد انه
القى خطابا بمثل كلمه المبادره عقار ما
قاله عقار هو
يختلف عن
خطاباتي البرهان البرهان رجل العسكري وليس
سياسي مبادره عقار نحن نرحب بها ووزاره
الخارجيه اطلعتني على انها خطوه تقنيه
جيده البرهان عاده يرسل اشارات لكن ليس
بالوضوح التي الوضوح الذي يجب ان يكون
عليه الاشارات تتحدث بانه يمكن قبول الدعم
السريع وهذا ما اشار له السيد
مارد عقار فقط بان يتم تجميعهم في نقاط
معينه ومن بعد درجههم في الله في المؤسسه
العسكريه وانا في تقدير هذه الجزيره هي
التي فجر ت الخلاف ومعلومه تماما اذا تم
تطبيق شروط في المؤسسه العسكريه على
القيادات العليا مثل محمد حمدان الى ذلك
لا يستوفون هذه الشروط وهذه هي يعني في
تقديرك جزئيات التي اسهمت بشكل مباشر في
اندلاع هذه المواجهات
اعتقد ان كل عمليات تحقيق السلام اذا كانت
التي في جثه او ايجاد كلها لديها هدف واحد
وفيه مكون يتعلق
بهده ووقف اطلاق النار وحوار سياسي القضيه
تعتمد على من وكيف تتم هذه
الترتيبات بامكاننا ان نفترض بعض الامور
وفقا لاي من هذه الاتفاقات لكن ينبغي ان
تتم وتبحث بشكل مسبق احسى العقبات المهمه
هنا كل الطرفين يحاولوا محو قياده الطرف
الاخر وحسب المعلومات المتوفره من خلال
تصريحات
انه هنالك خط للتواصل الساخن والخاص بينه
وبين على ادوار الفجر التي قضاها بالخارج
وهنالك التسريبات التي صدرتها
كانت حديثه ومهمه بينه وبين عدد من قيادات
القوه السياسيه علمنا ذلك من مصادر
مختلفه وحتى من بعض الشخصيات التي التقاها
لكن في تقدير الان باي حال من الاحوال
التحدي بيتمثل في امكانيه تطبيق هذه
المبادره على ارض الواقع مسار جده مهم لان
الامريكان كقوع عالميه والسعوديه كقوه
اقليميه ممكن ان تدعم اي مسار وايضا داخل
المنظومه ايجاد ايضا التي تبدو خطه بديله
[موسيقى]
الاتفاق الايطالي انتهى بذراع هذه الحرب
وقوع الحريه والتغيير ذاتها هي تعلم بذلك
تماما ولا حديث عن الاتفاق الاطاري ما
السابق لان الجيش الذي الان يحارب الدعم
السريع والدعم السريع الذي يحارب الجيش
وما كان طرفين في الاتفاق الايطالي جيد ان
كلا الطرفين ان يحترم
اتفاقات او تفاهمات جده لنعود الى عمليه
تفاوضيه مبادره عقار جيده هي اعتقد انها
لم تكن استجابه لما قاله البرهاندا ما
قدمه حمدته قبل ذلك ربما قد لا تؤدي الى
نتيجه لكن على الاقل لدينا شيء مطروح على
الطاوله